allow the pendulum to clear your mind
look through it behind the pendulum
right there
regression has all of the components of
a psychological thriller sort of horror
movie but it has a deeper layer to it
the memories are obviously in there
behind some door it's not that difficult
to find a key and free them provoke a
regression you know there's a lot of
horror movies and thrillers and genre
movies but I think Alejandro is
exploring superstition in a really
interesting way we know there was
someone else in the room your father
said something about a ritual regression
means among other things going back and
in this case it was like going back to
the movies at least enjoy as a viewer
and also the kind of movies that I used
to make when I started as a film
director
Alejandro's movies are you know a smart
man's horror film if you want to be
challenged intellectually emotionally
and if you want to be on the edge of
your seat and really experience me
that's genuinely very dark and very
scary
that's what Alejandra does she took me
downstairs it was a black mass there was
blood I wanted to try a suspense movie
that would take the matter seriously not
with that kind of ironic detached I
wanted to do something very serious and
very contained
we looked for several houses trying to
find the perfect farm for the story
which had to tell two things one the
family drama and also the tragedy and
the horrifying things that happen the
devil doesn't exist
the regressions we wanted to do it the
analogical way which is trying the
autofocus for real he knows exactly what
he wants but he's very passionate about
collaboration it's interesting to see
how through the collaborative process
with such little suddenly became
something very special
it does evil itself I just get this
feeling with this case it's a part of
something bigger
look how are you do
you